the jurogan experience
they show them the new missile they've
developed and uh but it has kind of a
round
round head and he says uh you need to
make it more pointy
to his engineers and uh
actually that's why i also decided the
same thing um you know starship we need
to make it more pointy
did you say that mm-hmm because of the
movie yeah really
yeah hold on
that's you literally told them to make
the starship more pointy
because of the movie the dictator yep um
and they know it too it's not like they
it's not like they haven't they're
unaware of it
everyone thought it would be funny if we
made the rocket more pointy so we did
did it have any effect on the
aerodynamics no nothing no we can make
it
way blunter and be fine but it was is it
better to be pointier like if it wasn't
for that
arguably
but more fun for you it looks cooler
well okay it does look cool
yeah yeah
how long do you think it'll be before
are you good jimmy
my head's maybe yeah exactly good
how long my head is sticking out is that
where it's
right on the edge of the top it's all
good oh is that supposed to be okay
you're good
all right how long do you think it's
going to be before you have like
regular flights with that where you can
take off and land and like an airplane
where it'll be
very consistent with our extra pointy
rocket you were your extra pointy rocket
do you mean earth to earth transport
or or to earth to orbit or anywhere yes
people are people any time where you
could just do it with people
and have them have it land all the time
um i think you're probably two hours
away two years away yeah
that's that's that's really nice two
years is pretty cool
it's yours for people we'll we'll we'll
have a lot of flights between down there
that's crazy that's
20 23 is not that far away that'll be
there before you know it
yeah wow 2023 10 flies
how many times have you had explosions
when you're on a rocket um
i don't know like uh quite a few six
maybe
five or six what are those like what is
it like when you watch it explode
when it's supposed to land and it just
now this is a test program
we expect it to explode um
it's weird if it doesn't explode frankly
really yeah
um because we're trying to develop
advanced rockets
at a high at a high speed and uh if you
want to get payloads orbit
uh you you have to run things close to
the edge
and um the whole rocket is evolving the
engines the structure
the avionics the software the ground
systems
are all evolving simultaneously so and
the whole production system which is
actually harder than the rocket design
by far
so the the rocket and engine and
avionics production system
is and the launch system uh is
a thousand percent harder than the
initial design like at least
really yeah so when same with cars it's
like ten thousand percent
and it's easy to do a car prototype it's
hard to do production
um so when you're looking at you're
scaling
towards the future and you're looking at
mistakes or uh corrections
improvements and all these different
things that's how you come up with this
figure of
approximately two years if current
trends continue
uh if we excited you know if you plot
the points on the curve
of progress then then we should be doing
regular
uh orbital flights with a high
probability of
uh safe landing in two years so
we're getting to orbit this year our
goal is to get over this year
so and and i'm not sure people totally
understand like
starship is the largest playing object
ever
made uh this thing will be
about over 5000 tons uh weight on
liftoff
is going to go straight up 5.5 000 turns
um
this is much heavier than any aircraft
by far there's no
no aircraft even comes close to this uh
with weight
um and it's going straight up the
aircraft can't go straight up so it's
like the
it's got more than twice it will have
more than twice the thrust of a saturn v
really yeah yeah it's like a big rocket
why does it need that much thrust
oh we're trying because you want to go
to mars
or is this like we're trying to make
life multi-planetary
you know uh extend life beyond earth and
in order to do that you have to have
high tonnage to
mars and that means you need a big
rocket and you gotta fly a lot
so the reason why it has twice the
thrust of the saturn five
is to plan for these interstellar trips
uh interpreting interplanetary trips so
when you when you're doing this and
you're
you're you're developing these systems
thinking about regular trips to other
planets
but you're not you're not just trying to
get into orbit right now you're trying
to get into orbit with something that
eventually could scale up
yeah we know how to get to orbit we've
done that a lot so
the the really hard thing is
we need to have a fully and rapidly
reusable rocket where the
where all elements of the rocket are
reused and they're reused quickly like
an aircraft
um and this has never been done this is
the holy grail of rocketry
this is uh to have a fully uh reusable
rocket then you need to go one step
further
it needs to be fully and rapidly
reusable you know it's like
like a plane yeah yeah like plane lands
you
uh you know refuel it and take off again
how do you have time
this i i never understand you in regards
to the the way
you run multiple businesses
simultaneously
i would think that something like this
would require so much concentration
it would require this i would think this
would be
your whole being trying to figure out
how to work this
um yeah well i do work a lot
but it's crazy and i thought just for a
reason as late as i looked like coming
from
from me uh you know some critical
meetings just doing
normally i'd be meeting until i work
until like one or two in the morning
every night not i mean saturday
sunday usually not but sometimes how
much do you sleep
about six hours oh that's pretty good
yeah not that crazy
for you that's i mean for someone does
as much as you that's actually
that's impressive that you can squeeze
that in yeah
i try i've tried sleeping less but then
total uh
productivity decreases yeah so you feel
like six is the number where it's yeah
six six uh
six or six is i can that um
i i don't find myself needed wanting
more sleep than sex so
when like with the saturn v and the
space shuttles and
all these other rockets you they would
they would have these
parts that would they would get the
ship up into space but they would
descend down to earth and
crash into the ocean and they would
never use them again that's right
how do you avoid that like what is the
difference between the way this these
things are structured like
the the whole thing goes together and
then it lands together
um well we're on the wrong planet for a
single stage to orbit
right um i think one thing to appreciate
is like space
getting to space is easy getting to
orbit as hard
so you only need maybe one or two
percent of the energy
to get to space to where the atmosphere
is thin compared to what you need to get
to orbit
and if you get to orbit now you've got
to burn off all that energy and you're
coming in like a meteor
so you need a powerful heat shield so
it's like
super difficult to get to orbit at all
and then if you get to orbit at all then
making those
the stages reusable means they're going
to come back intact
uh and then the upper stage is
especially difficult because it's got so
much energy all the energy you put into
it you have to take out
um so it's a
you know you're literally coming in like
a flaming meteor
and and most things would just melt and
vapor melt or vaporize so
like if you as human try to come in from
orbit you just be
pink mist yeah
a funny way to put it yeah catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely
free you don't have to have a premium
account to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience